as a
small little quirk of history it seems
like you're
related to jordan peterson like you
mentioned
he's going through some rough stuff now
is there some comment you can make about
the the roughness of the human journey
the ups and downs
well i i became an expert
in uh benzo withdrawal
like which is you took benzodiazepines
and at some point
they interact with gaba circuits
you know to reduce anxiety and do 100
other things like there's actually
no known list of everything they do
because they interact with so many parts
of your body
and then once you're on them you
habituate to them and you're you're
you have a dependency it's not like
you're a drug dependency we're trying to
get high
it's a it's a metabolic dependency
and then if you discontinue them
there's a funny thing called kindling
which is if you stop them
and then go you know you'll have a
horrible thrall symptoms if you go back
on them at the same level you won't be
stable
and that unfortunately happened to him
because it's so deeply integrated into
all the
kinds of systems in the body it
literally changes the size and numbers
of
neurotransmitter sites in your brain
yeah so there's a there's a
process called the ashton protocol where
you taper it down slowly over two years
to people go through that go through
unbelievable hell
and what jordan went through seemed to
be worse because
yeah on advice of doctors you know we'll
stop taking these and take this
it was the disaster and he got some
yeah it was pretty tough um he seems to
be doing
quite a bit better intellectually you
can feel his brain clicking back
together
i spent a lot of time with i've never
seen anybody suffer so much well his
brain is also like this
powerhouse right so i wonder does a
brain
that's able to think deeply about the
world suffer more through these kinds of
withdrawals like
i don't know i've watched videos of
people going through withdrawal
they all seem to suffer unbelievably
and you know my work goes out to
everybody
and there's some funny math about this
some doctors said as best you can tell
you know there's the standard
recommendations don't take them for more
than a month and then taper over a
couple of weeks
many doctors prescribe them endlessly
which is against the protocol but
it's common right and then
something like 75 percent of people when
they taper
it's you know half the people have
difficulty but 75
get off okay 20 percent have severe
difficulty and five percent have
life-threatening difficulty
and if you're one of those it's really
bad and the stories
that people have on this is
heartbreaking and
tough so you put some of the fault that
the doctors that just not know what the
hell they're doing
oh no it's hard to say it's it's one of
those commonly prescribed things like
one doctor said what happens is if
you're prescribed them for a reason
and then you have a hard time getting
off the protocol basically says you're
either crazy
or dependent and you get kind of pushed
into a different treatment regime you're
a drug
drug addict or a psychiatric patient and
so
like one doctor said you know i
prescribed them for 10 years thinking i
was helping my patients and i realized i
was really harming them
and you know the awareness of that is
slowly coming up
the fact that they're casually
prescribed to people
is horrible and it's bloody scary
and some people are stable on them but
they're on them for life like once
you know it's another one of those drugs
that but benzo's long range have real
impacts on your personality people talk
about the benzo bubble where you get
disassociated from reality and your
friends a little bit
it's it's it's it's really terrible the
mind is terrifying we're talking about
how
how the infinite possibility are fun but
like
it's the infinite possibility of
suffering too which is one of the
dangers of
uh like expansion of the human mind it's
like
i wonder if all the possible human
experiences that an
intelligent computer can have is it
mostly fun
or is it mostly suffering so like if you
if you uh brute force expand
the set of possibilities like are you
going to run into some trouble
in terms of like torture and suffering
and so on maybe our human brain is just
protecting us from
much more possible pain and suffering
maybe the space of pain
it's like much larger than we could
possibly imagine and that
the world's in the balance you know all
the
all the literature on religion and stuff
is you know the struggle between court
good and evil is
is balanced versus very finely tuned for
reasons that are complicated
but that's a that's a long philosophical
conversation
you